a little bit more separation on those  down screws  paul barging ahead and finds his spot  and rattles it in for the deuce paul  sizing him up  paul trying to punch it down low jokic  comes out on him shot clock at one he's  got a fire  around two screens chris paul on the fly  two screens paul ready to fire boy he  cannot miss  he is on automatic hall of famer to be  and he puts his sons up by six  oh it is so hard to close all right  see how he won't switch look at paul  weave  look at paul fire look at him  36 is he 36 when he wasn't playing  defensively to check him out the game  and those guys would play look at that  play  no he is a magician chris paul  a sleight of hand he  [Music]  [Applause]  i mean an arresting talent that's right  [Music]  [Applause]  for the ages